stop trying to hit me
okay see what you're doing recording the
matrix
all right morpheus let's dance
that's good maybe i start trying now
okay now you're gonna start trying i see
you
i'll see you where'd he come from
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder we
just got a little teaser of what
shang chi and the legend of the tin
rings is going to be like
this morning actor simul liu who of
course is going to be playing shang chi
in the upcoming film
shared this video on twitter with the
caption messed around
with some legendary talented friends in
sydney last year then he listed the few
people in the video now what's really
awesome about this video is
it really is a teaser of what's to come
in chiang chi and the legend of the ten
rings that's because the three people in
this video fighting are all actually a
part of shang chi
vin dan tran in this video is one of the
action designers of shang chi
and zak wang is a part of the stunt team
so this
is what the action scenes in shanghai
are going to look like this is a little
bit of a preview
a lot of fans were kind of worried that
the action and the fighting sequences
were going to be
a little like iron fist but this video
that cemu shared shows us the opposite
it shows us that the fighting sequences
in the film are going to be
incredible not to mention they also cast
michelle yeo in this movie who is
absolutely incredible at fighting and
filming
fight sequences there's also a lot of
humor in this video that semu shared and
his personality really shines
it leads us to believe that not only is
sheng chi going to be absolutely
action-packed but it's going to have a
humor aspect to it as well which many
marvel films do have
this combined with an insanely good
story you know marvel is going to do for
shang chi
makes this movie a very highly
anticipated film coming up next year and
in phase 4.
so let me know what you think about this
video in the comments down below let me
know how excited you are for shang chi
and the legend of the 10 rings be sure
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a modoc
funko pop from the avengers game
provided by heroeshideout.com
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof